hi there my name is Liz and I'm a
necessary teaching google cloud
customers how to build and operate
reliable services and I'm Seth a
developer advocate focused on
infrastructure and operations in the
previous episode we discussed SL OS and
error budgets as a means of balancing
availability and new feature development
in this episode Liz and I discussed toil
so Liz from what I understand toil is
just work that I don't like to do so
emails meetings commuting to work so
what can I do to reduce my toil hold on
a second Seth those things aren't
specifically toil so we call those
things overhead because there's things
that are not directly tied to a
production service so they're just a
requirement of any office job really
most people at the company not just a
Suri's have to expense reports and so
forth and that's not really toil okay so
if toil isn't just work that I don't
like to do what is it then toil is the
kind of work that's tied to running a
production service that tends to be
manual repetitive Arum a double tactical
and devoid of long-term value
additionally toil tends to scale
linearly as a service grows
I see so each time an operator needs to
touch a production system that
represents some toil time but what if I
codify all of the times that I need to
touch it and I just run a script instead
of manually running the commands you've
reduced the amount of toil you have to
do but you haven't made it not toil
because you still have to run that
script every single time the system
requires an intervention so that still
is manual and it gets to even worse the
larger service grows because you have to
keep doing it over and over and over
again okay but and you also said
something the task has to be repetitive
too so if I just do it maybe once or
twice is that still toil or no that is
probably not toil at least the first or
second time or at least it's not toil
that's worth automating you really want
to automate toil when it gets to the
point that you're doing it three or four
times or where you're taking hours and
hours out of your day
I see so if a task can be automated it
probably should be automated what about
things that are pretty common in
operations like you know page or alerts
so pager alerts are almost always toil
because of the fact that they're
interrupts driven and there
reactive you don't know when it's going
to happen and just swallows a bunch of
your time just to get the system back to
where it was before okay so what if I
get paged in the middle of the night to
provision additional capacity for a
service so I you know I look through the
system and I realized that the only way
to do this is manually I have to click
buttons I have to run commands so I do
that I get the service back up and
running and I go back to sleep and in
the morning I wake up and I realize that
I need to automate this so I spent about
six or seven hours building some
automation so that the service can scale
automatically in the future a that's a
lot of toil how do we how do we account
for that not quite because of the fact
that the time that you spent during the
middle of the night between when you got
paged and when the system returned to
normal from your manual action that's
toil however the latter part of what you
did during the day that's a worthwhile
project that actually reduces the toy
over time because the toy has no
enduring value but the automation that
you do in order to reduce the amount of
toil you do that's real useful work I
see and I think it's clear now why
you've coined a new term to define this
type of work there's always going to be
tasks that you don't want to do like
overhead like email and meetings and
commuting and expense reports and
there's always going to be kind of
operationally grungy tasks like
restarting services that that are devoid
of long-term value so they are actually
toil in certain cases in previous
episodes we talked about how everything
in sre is measured though so how do we
measure toil so there are two ways that
we measure toil first of all we try to
concentrate the toil in two blocks for
instance during your on call week so you
don't get pages and tickets off of your
on call week so it makes it a lot easier
to measure when is toil when is not toil
additionally we have people track their
toil time sometimes by sampling and we
send quarterly surveys to make sure that
people understand how are their time is
spent on toil do they feel like they
have more room and then toil is also
everyone's responsibility so we'll often
ask the product development software
engineers to measure their amount of
toil as well so make sure that we're
spending everyone's time well so you
mentioned that the goal should be to
reduce toil shouldn't the goal be to
eliminate toil entirely how does the
problem with eliminating toil entirely
is that there are often tasks they're
not worth automating
like if you spent an hour fixing
something by hand and it happens maybe
three times a year but it would take you
ten hours to write the automation that's
going to have a very long pay off
threshold whereas if you have something
that's firing all the time you might
want to go and get it out of your way
so as you reduce the amount of toil and
leave along the things that are not
worth automating you'll find that
there's some amount of toil associated
with each service you can keep the total
amount of toil you do somewhere between
thirty and fifty percent of your time
and spend the rest of your time doing
worthwhile projects that reduce the toil
so that over time you can accept more
responsibility for more services or your
service can just naturally grow in size
and have your amount of workload remain
constant I see so sres get to spend at
least half if not two-thirds of their
time working on real engineering work
the SR e stands for site reliability
engineering so they get to focus on
things like improving reliability
performance utilization monitoring and
all of those things can actually reduce
toil in the future as well yes it's
exactly correct and also we share our
best practices so when we do these items
of research into how we make our
services better we can often apply them
across multiple different essary teams
so polish white papers within the
company or on our blog describing to us
arrays how they might make sure that
their toil but stays low and within
budget so that we can spend more time
making our services better in the long
term at the end of the day the e and s
are e stands for engineering and
engineering work is really what lets our
organizations scale and meet the demands
of all of the applications and services
and machines that we support great this
has been really helpful and I think I
have a much better understanding of toil
and its negative consequences but oil
isn't always entirely negative sometimes
it's worthwhile to have some amount of
predictable and automatable work for
individual people to cut their teeth on
for instance let's suppose that you have
someone new to your team that wants to
learn how does the system actually work
before you put them on call oh you might
have them poke around at the system
manually in order to fix something that
you already had lying around also it's
really helpful to have things that
people feel satisfied by doing where
they get an immediate reward rather than
working at a project for the long term
and not necessarily knowing when it's
going to finish so sometimes it's
helpful for people to do those tasks in
the short term but we don't think it's a
good idea for people to focus entirely
on doing toil because that doesn't
really advance the engineering part of
their job and it can cause career
stagnation and unhappiness in the long
term so toil and toil budgets do not
have a direct relation to the DevOps
pillars that we've discussed in previous
episodes but they do closely influence
the desire to measure everything and
reduce organizational silos by giving
operators a quantitative measurement
toil and toil budgets ensure a balance
between administering the system and
improving it this has really helped a
lot I think it's a lot clearer now why
we say that class sre implements DevOps
thank you to everyone for watching don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
also stay tuned for our next video where
we discuss how Google teaches essary
practices to customers through the
customer reliability engineering program